37 year old making his 28th start but
for the cardinals his ninth he's pitched
138 innings and here's the thing you got
to worry about with jhap a lot of
traffic in those 138 innings he is
allowed with hits and walks and hit
batsman
208 base runners andre is going to try
and get j hat
in the air here this afternoon see if
they can play some long ball against the
cardinals and pick up a game in those
wild card standings as tati slips a high
fly ball into deep right field back in
carlson oh he caught it what a catch
how about this start
an incredible play
dylan carlson and right
what a way to start the ball game wow to
make the first out of a game in that
fashion to take extra bases away
and that was going to be a double maybe
a triple depending on where the ball
bounced off the wall but carlson didn't
let the ball hit the wall at all what a
great route what a great catch mr
arietta born in the show me state
farmington missouri jake arrieta four
start as a padre
last outing tuesday against the giants
three and two-thirds the three-run ball
on five hits
opponents hitting 3-15 we talked about
base runners over the course of the
season overall in the 98 in the third
hits walks hit batters 177 base runners
bases loaded
nobody out
nolan
orenado trying to become the first
cardinal with a hundred driven in since
his good buddy matt holliday
in 2012
the fly ball into shallow center
to tease dropped it
he drops it
the throw to the plate not in time
the cardinals score run and still nobody
out he tried to get tommy edmond
thank you very much one nothing saint
louis
he drops the baseball because he's
looking at the runner he's such a
shallow center field he didn't have to
rush that but now he throws to the wrong
base he had an out at third he's got no
chance to get tommy edmund and frazier's
telling him throw to third throw to
third and he picked the wrong base
shift on the right side still nobody out
bases loaded and dylan carlson
carlson lifts the fly ball to left
fielder
tommy fan runner from third will tag up
and score that's paul goldschmidt and
it's two to nothing st louis carlson
drives in his 58. two-nothing cardinals
lead here in the first so so the sixth
man to bat here in the first inning
still just one away arianna trying to
limit the damage
[Applause]
down one run will score sosa on his way
to second and he's made it a
three-nothing saint louis lead
fiesta cardinales and sosa with a double
to make it three-nothing
mundito does it again
every game he does something to help you
win
so it is fiesta cardinales from the
country of panama the only cardinal
player from there
arietta will depart in the first inning
with one out for the second time in four
starts as a padre he leaves with an
injury kirk's damn first guy out runners
on second and third still only one away
with the cardinals leading by three in
the first inning vader base hit
down into the corner two runs will score
harrison off to the races
he'll stop at second base it's five
nothing
st louis
that's bader going the other way i love
the approach
[Applause]
and of course the result
stamen
frankly has had a very good year for the
padres
and i think they went to him in this
inning because i think jase tingler
knows
we need help right now so runner in
scoring position now for the padres with
two down and the lead off man fernando
tatis junior coming to the plate hard
hit and through the left side for a base
hit frazier will go from third o'neal's
throw to the plate is cut off
and the padres are on the board as
fernando tatis jr comes through again
with two outs and runners in scoring
position runners on second and third
here for the padres is eric hosmer steps
to the plate on the ground to first base
goldschmidt will flick to half cover
padres get another here in the fourth as
manny checks in three-run game as noel
over to third base and with will myers
coming up first pitch swinging ground
ball right back off the foot of happen
it's going to roll into right field for
a base hit and on the play austin nola
is going to score
rbi single for will myers and the padres
have indeed cut the lead down to five to
three
got ourselves a ball game
padres
chipping away
brought his lead within two
rbi single off the foot
of jay happen into right field
and the line continues to move at first
it looked like it was going to get
through up the middle and then it just
barely nicked the back left heel of half
standing quickly ahead of kisner owen
two andrew kisner the back up for yachty
air molina ground ball left side it's
going to be fielded by manny fairball
off balance throw in time over to eric
hosmer two away nice play by manny
typical manny play going towards his
right catching the ball heading into
foul territory but able to flip it over
to haws for the out two away padres
trailing the cardinals by a score of
five to three there's tyler o'neal
walked his first time up and is struck
out
and a run scored o'neal the base hit
into center
here comes goldie he will score and
tyler o'neill delivers again and it's a
6-3 st louis lead
cardinals now extend their lead to 6-3
two outs two on and the next two so-so
sosa hits a fly ball into shallow right
field this goal will be
court no it gets away
a run will score sosa to second
myers had it lost it 7-3 st louis they
trail the card 7-3 as we head into the
top of the sixth inning one down here's
tommy pham first pitch to tommy swinging
lion driving to left field well hit this
ball is gone a home run for tommy pham
first pitch swinging he ambushes that
one 14th home run of the season for
tommy pham and the padres now trailing
cars by a score of 7-4 runner on second
base dylan carlson will now come to the
plate for the cardinals ground ball up
the middle base hit dylan carlson
extends the st louis lead to eight to
four
brings in tyler o'neill
dylan
has driven into today eight to four
cardinals
now all of a sudden padres runners on
first and second as tommy pham who's
homer in this game already steps to the
plate that's it well out to left field
and that's going to find the corner for
tommy pham
jake cronenworth's going to come in and
score machado is rounding third manny is
on his way the relay to the plate this
is an eight to six game in the eighth
and still nobody out runner on third
and eric hosmer coming to the plate
that could get it done and it will
goldschmidt flipping to cabrera just in
time to get hosmer but pam checks in
this is a one-run game in the eighth
minute eight to seven cardinals trying
to hold on and sweep the san diego
padres
fly ball into center you won eight in a
row you got it
it's a sweep of san diego it's 10 games
above 500
and this team is rolling
[Applause]